[Music]
[Applause]
alright this in case you don't know this
is a segment where viewers they watch
the show and they try to find mistakes
that we've made all right we've been
doing this for a while so far
hundreds of challengers not one winner
nobody has caught us making mistake
because because we don't make them we
don't make mistakes it's flawless show I
mean aside from hiring we don't make and
my occasional drug to pay you we don't
make mistakes well tonight a fan from
Ecuador named ax man says he thinks he
caught a mistake he says it happened
when I was making a joke about wheel of
fortune host Pat Sajak a conan man you
made a mistake dude on the episode that
aired Wednesday May 21st you were
mocking Pat Sajak mocking people in his
controversial tweets about global
warming and you lamely joked that I'm a
scientist told Sajak they would like to
buy an app into you this week Wheel of
Fortune host Pat Sajak mocked people who
believe in global warming yeah in
response climate scientist told sage act
I'd like to buy an F Andy you well
anyone who's watched Wheel of Fortune
even one time knows that you don't buy
consonants you buy vowels so unless
you're planning to mount a national
campaign to change the structure of the
whole English language I'd say that you
dude have made a giant F mistake so
who's mocking who now
[Applause]
well I'm sorry axeman although your
impression of me is spot-on Annie what's
the head-on can yeah it's me and my
after I've had a child with r2d2 anyway
anyway I'm afraid that you are dead
wrong on this issue you say anyone who's
watched Wheel of Fortune even one time
knows you can't buy consonants well
ax men it sounds like you've only
watched Wheel of Fortune one time
otherwise you'd know Wheel of Fortune
bends its rules once a year during its
special High Roller edition of The Game
Show
ladies and gentlemen here's an actual
clip from one of those episodes welcome
back to high rollers week on Wheel of
Fortune the category for our next round
is phrase and Adam it's your turn to
start great Pat if I could I'd like to
buy a vowel is the letter F available
you know technically F is not a vowel
although what's an F worth to you I
don't know about 800 bucks but I'd love
to buy a letter M I'm sorry no M be sure
it's not even for 1,500 bucks
all right yeah anybody else need
anything how about that watch Derek
Jeter rookie card the tops are done Russ
I'm kind of hungry
I'll give it 50 bucks for a pizza make
me a blonde
I want a turtle what a tortoise be ok
can I run up there and turn around all
the way that's gonna cost you
[Applause]
[Music]
that's it and the puzzle is in your face
Axman
[Applause]
[Music]
well the challenge still stands if you
think you've spotted an error on our
show reported at team koco.com / haha I
found an error we will sort it out right
here on the air let's see if you've got
what it takes to make chunk meat out of
the maestro we have an excellent
[Applause]
you